the most recent statistics show the
number of americans providing unpaid
care has increased over the last five
years from 43 million to 53 million so
who cares for the caregivers as many may
agree it takes a village
from scheduling doctor visits to cooking
cleaning running errands and now facing
precautions at every turn due to covid
the responsibilities caregivers take on
during an already emotional time can be
overwhelming often what we hear from
caregivers is the burdens put back on
them when we ask a question like how can
i help
and so i invite people instead of saying
how can i help instead say here's what i
can do and be very specific tia newcomer
is the ceo of caringbridge a non-profit
social network that rallies communities
around caregivers and people on health
journeys caringbridge is a great example
a free online site where you can
journal ask for help give health updates
in one click but i think the most
important thing is we know if people
feel like
they have a community behind them and
are in their corner their anxiety levels
reduce by up to 30 so that's a really
big
big
improvement if you can have that
communication in place visit
caringbridge.org caregiver for more